[Applause]
dispatch 5
how's it going bud what you looking for
first registration oh okay then yeah you
can go in the glove boook if you need to
hey I'm not trying to give any of you
guys any promps no you're not okay I'm
just like I said I'm going to give you
guys my card let you know no I don't
want your card I need your registration
buddy hey I'm not I'm going to find
whatever you guys
can I ask a question well how long's
that open bottle of Corona been back
there fucking Le 3 or 4 days 3 or 4 days
okay then uh do you know where your
registration is in the vehicle uh at
least um April
24 would you know where it is in the
vehicle yeah I there's there's no an
open bottle
of that that that I can see there's a
glass bottle of I believe it' to be
Corona back there I was just asking yeah
but I can assure you that I live two
blocks away okay have you had any
alcohol to drink tonight not in like
fucking what is it it's uh midnight like
6 7 hours yeah it's uh 11:40 right now 6
7 hours okay how much do you have do you
have to drink uh three 3 or 4 beers
three or four beers where was
it uh at the restaurant at Famous
another secondary question this is
expired by like four months do you have
like a newer one or a more recent one I
definitely do okay that's totally
fine that's fine so I'm just going to
put this right up here with
you let me
go no just taking it
s
so where'd you get that wristband
at uh
probably the whatever club that is by
next to
uh I don't even know I don't go often
okay next to uh the
place give me a
second thank you
not going to lie to guys
fucking Slaters the club plge Slaters
okay when when were you this is what I'm
going to have you do like two hours ago
okay you have that wristband on there's
an open container in your car I'm to
have you step out of the vehicle okay
hey that open container was like fucking
weeks ago yep well you know you can't
have an open container in the state of
North Dakota okay so I'm going to have
you step out of the vehicle
okay can you give me 5 Seconds no can
you unlock your vehicle so we can step
out
back no that's only fine I just wanted
you know no we're just having a quick
little conversation okay I'm up you
going to do it yeah can do I'm pH
so what I'm going to do yes sir I I I
don't mean to be any no you're good so
you said it's been 6 hours since you had
your last drink yes sir okay then so
7:00 p.m. it's like 2: a.m. now okay I
live two blocks away okay so what I'm
going to do I'm going to I want to
conduct a series of FS variety tests
okay to make sure you're good to drive
cuz I smell alcohol in your breath and
you're slurring your words a little I
said with the the Slater's wristband but
you said you're coming from famous days
um so I just want to run some uh field
soety tests you happy to do that
absolutely why not also disp the
Delta I don't mean
TOA I'm being roadside this drive period
all right
so
yeah
do something can I have you open up your
mouth and take your open up your mouth
no not blow it yeah lift your tongue up
lift your tongue up to the roof of your
mouth perfect thank you all you're good
you can
stop so like I said if you just stay
standing dra your feet together and
hands on my side what I'm actually going
to do we're going to go over to the
sidewalk just that way we're away from
traffic
bud you can do some bro all
right take care take care that's right
no I don't want you on the ice you just
take a couple of steps
back all right so I'm just going to test
and make sure you're well when you do
you see the tip of my pen and just look
at the tip of my pen for a sec and just
hold that the bottom or top the the top
the tip of it got
you and then what I want you to do I
want you to follow the pen with your
eyes and your eyes on there
okay what I want you to do I want you to
follow with your eyes and your eyes only
don't move your head okay do you
understand yes sir I got you
okay okay then now just keep following
it with your eyes and your eyes only
okay yes
sir
for
it's hard because the lights right there
okay well it's just the outside of this
in your
eyes if you guys are trying to ruin me
and destroy me I mean
me you guys are doing your job just keep
following with your eyes okay we're
nearly
done
I'm nowhere near drunk I'm two blocks
away okay just keep behind somebody for
me please bu I I I'm mean no trouble
[Applause]
sir okay would you like me to do a dance
just one more just uh what we're going
to do we're going to go up now okay so
same thing just follow your eyes and
your eyes only hey where you from can I
can
come just uh I need to do this test
right bud just stand still your feet
together and your arms stand by side
please where you from with your accent
okay if you don't continue the test I'm
going to take as a refuser right sorry
yeah no I I'm not going to refuse guys
because OB guys are cops just put your
feet together time just follow your eyes
and your
please you keep my head straight yeah
please
up yes
sir okay so we're going to move on to
another test called walk and turn test
so what I'm going to have you do is if
you just step back a little just so we
can uh actually we'll use uh it's we're
going to use this L where's atog okay
all right so what I'm going to have you
do if you if you put your arms on by
your side and put your right foot in
front of your left foot heels touch and
toes and I want you to hold that
position while I demonstrate and explain
this so what you're going to do you're
going to use this line I'm going to
demonstrate it without the line so from
the position you're in with your right
foot heel touching your toe you're going
to take nine Heel To Toe
steps and on the ninth step you're going
to conduct a series of small steps and
you're going to walk backwards nine
steps it's going to look like
this one 2 3 simulating this is your
ninth step is a serious of small turns
small steps and continue
back until that test is complete do you
understand yes sir you want to go nine
and turn around yeah do you need me to
explain and demonstrate again I got it
okay then you may begin when you're
ready two three 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 okay did n
* two so next step we're going to do or
the next test we're going to do is the
one leg stand so do me a favor just
stand together your feet together your
arms down by your side arms down by your
side please so with a foot of your
choice it can be the left foot or the
right foot it's your choice you're going
to raise it approximately 9 you're going
to raise it approximately 6 in off of
the ground keeping your foot
level you're going to look down at your
foot and you're going to count out loud
1001 100002
1003 up to 30 it's going to look like
this so for me I'm going to choose my
left foot 1,1 10002 13 1004 and you're
going to count all the way till 30 do
you understand yes sir okay when I get
to 30 what do you want me to do so once
you've completed once you once you start
don't stop and then once you've
completed once you don't think 30
seconds has passed he'll he'll let you
know when it starts I'll let you know
when to stop okay I'm confused do you
want to make steps after 30,000 do you
do you want me to explain the instructor
again one more time yes so with the foot
of your choice it can be left or right
you're going to ra you're going to raise
it approximately 6 in off of the ground
and you're going to keep it level with
the Earth and you're going to count out
loud while looking at your foot 1,1
10002 13 all the way until you're told
to stop okay so it's going to look like
this 1,1 1,2 1,3 1,4 and you're going to
do that until you're told to stop
I can do that yes sir all right and your
in time you can startop 1,2 23 3 4
five
six I'm going to get on a flat
surface 7
8 9
10 11
12 holy
shit 13 14
15 16
17 okay that's perfect you can stop
B I just need to uh my colleague might
be grabbing a bit of paper I'm going to
read you something um are you grabbing
it all right
cool all right so I'm going to read you
something here it's a little bit uh
wordy but I have to read it verbatim so
it might sound a little funny okay hey
can I ask you a few things just uh let
me read this real quick cuz I got to
read this to you okay the officer sh
form the IND idual that North go Law
requires the individual to take the
screening test to determine whether the
individual is under the influence of
alcohol and that refusal of the
individual to submit to a screening test
may result in revocation for at least
100 180 days and up to 3 years of the
individual's driving privileges do you
understand that yeah I understand sir so
what I'm going to request is that you
provide a speci breath in it's called an
aloh sensor otherwise known as a a
breathalizer yes sir are you happy to
provide that I'm not going to do that
that you know why why is up you guys
pick it cuz I'm like two blocks away
okay you guys are on me you know you
guys are going to you guys are going to
regret picking on me okay because you
don't know the just one second I'm going
to give I'm going to I'm going to give
you a chance I'm going to give you a
chance again will you provide the test
no sir okay you know what so this moment
time you under the dii
back I'm going to have uh another thing
that roll the cuff up cheers there's a
couple more things I need to read to
okay no I being trouble with you guys
get trouble with me just about the
do the rest
DUI all right so I'm put in back of your
car okay
uh I'm just going to read something real
quick you have the right to remain
silent you
sorry you have the right to remain
silent anything you do say Canon will be
used against you cour law you have the
right to an attorney and have them
present while being questioned if
attorney cannot if you cannot afford an
attorney one will be provided for you
prior to any question if you wish you
can decide at any time to exercise these
rights not make answer any questions
make any statements do you understand
these rights I read them to you with
these rights in mind you to talk to me
what that okay do you answer do you
understand these rights I've read them
to you with them mind you wish to talk
to me yes s so um Can can um what can I
do to to drive my truck off drop it off
my place uh I'm going to read you one
more thing and then uh we can worry
about your vehicle okay the law
enforcement officer shall inform the
individual North Law requires the
individual to take a chemical test to
determine whether the individual is
under the influence of alcohol and or
drugs and refusal of the individual to
submit to the test Direct by the law
enforcement officer may result in
verification of the driver's privileges
for a minimum of 180 days and up to 3
years so what this request is is down at
the jail there's another machine it's
called the in Oiler 8000 we be
requesting two specimens of breath from
you are you happy to submit to that can
we at least drop my please okay like two
blocks away Hey listen we're asking he's
asking you a question first let's start
with that are you willing to submit to
the Inox 8,000 or you not simple as that
yes or no I will submit that if you let
me draw you're not going to be driving
your vehicle okay no I so but what we
can do we can lock your vehicle okay and
we can bring the keys with us there's
two of you how many yeah I'm not driving
that car that far so this is two blocks
listen this what I can do though instead
of leaving it on that side and put it
over there I can put it right over there
I want to I want to drop my off we're
not doing that we're going to go to this
vehicle
okay we're going to go to the rear
passenger side of the vehicle okay
reason nobody respects
you okay there's no need for that
language
but you guys going R more than I will I
can't gue that all right just hold them
for a sec hold them for a sec just don't
go in yet okay as of everyone this
vehicle has been searched there's
nothing in there anything that's found
once you leave is going to be related to
you okay do you understand yes sir to so
it's easier to strap them then he I mean
no respect to
uh
put all right I'm just going to you
ain't got any weapons on on you have you
no sir all I'm just going to set real
quick there's no weapons on my car
either so what do you want us to do
about your car so what I can do is I can
walk your window shut your vehicle off
you can have your keys in your
possession so that when you are released
a sober individual can do it or I'll
tell you that's the best we're not
moving the car those that's your only
option I'll drive that to my place and I
we're not doing that no no no no you
good can you guys give me 5 Seconds are
you happy for us to par can give me 5
Seconds talk to you okay step in the car
Bud step in the car go ahead hey where
you from it
doesn't
light there it is all right where's the
keys to your vehicle and we'll we'll
turn it off and lock it it's inside my
uh uh transmission do you want them with
you simple yes or no uh no you don't
want them in you want them in your car
with you you want them to just life in
there we can leave your car just like
that if you want if you can pull it over
to somewhere where it won't get hit yeah
I can move it over more and I'll leave
it there shut it off yes sir all right
all right we'll do
that told you bro you dud dude I was
coming down here just to go over here
type my report and a hit right there
dude and the dude don't you know how
there's three lanes he went straight and
I was like all right I've done that I
was like cool and then he's just like
this like when they say you can I was
like oh hell
that's it's uh 93 who's uh in talk
right yeah the other ones will ask so
just ask if there's
avail
to PD units is there anybody available
to meet me in the jail for in
TOS do you want your uh phones there's
two phones in there do you want those
and do you want your I would take two
phones here that would appreciate okay
because I I got to call Attorney General
jley to let these guys know what you're
being an asshole to me okay just uh let
you know all this is video and audio
recorded on body camera including your
language right uh do you cameras right
here have you got a wallet it's in my
my okay have you got a wallet in the
vehicle that you want my wallet
is yes my my wallet's a
fuck y you it's in your pocket my left
ass pocket yes sir okay you want to hop
out I I'll grab that for you that way
that's uncomfortable for
you can you you think I'm going to run
from you leave you yes or no step out
I'll grab your wallet can you at least
put uh he did want his two phones yes
you want your two phones you want your
Co too yep no there's no there's no
wallet there first of all watch your
mouth man there's no wallet doing you a
favor you're doing me Shut the get in
the car get in the car get in the car
there's no wallet though get in the car
no get in the car oh so I don't he wall
me my bad nope not in there my
bad dude my fucking wrist hurting can
you Le solution
[Applause]
that
dude he's asking me to turn off my body
camera
no yeah I know oh God no I'm going to no
that's insane what uh let's search his
thing before
you so where you from with
that
dispatch uh origin from
[Music]
England
County uh there's just some
opportunity what's that again
I felt like there was
opportunity so how does you born in
England
yeah same as anyone
else what you went to the
academy the rest of Americans okay but I
mean that's a completely different uh
debate right
am I wrong or
right that's your opinion when were you
born in England what year that's not
relevant buddy that that's not
relevant do you love
England go ahead
sir so I can oh yeah I'll do that now
cheers I don't know what you mean are
you proud to be from England yeah I like
my country I have what yes I like my
country are you proud of English at
least why is that relevant
because why what are you doing here in
North Dakota arresting
people you're you're conscious being
taken over by migrants and and refugees
right am I
wrong you're arresting me for driving
home but people come into your country
and R your women yes or
no and I'm the fucking bad guy
yes or no tell
me tell me
bro yes or
no you can't even answer
me because you
know I don't
a I don't give
a I'll fight for you I'm going to fight
for the people in England or you ever
would you
little
am I wrong
bro Am I
Wrong yes or no am I wrong answer me
bro by
migrants thousands thousands every
week and you're ring me in North
Dakota how many of your friends and
family members have been calized and
terrorized by
migrants and you're arring me good for
you bro good
for you betrayed your people you sold
your people
off
you can't even answer me you can't even
respond to me you can't even look at me
you know I'm
right because you know I'm
right am I
wrong
we do
have
[Music]
you're
how long have you been in America
sir you can't even answer
me you can't even answer
me how long have you been in the United
States you're destroying your people in
Europe are being destroyed and raped in
pilgrimage and you're arresting
me
that's how pathetic and weak you
are I'm not even drunk and you know I'm
right you
fuck hey before it drop me
off I want to look at you I want you to
talk
what would you C your
ethnicity
Mexican put that foran
yeah you came
London
England Terror
people
fucking you
know
what the did I do to
you
nothing hey officer what's your
name officer what's your name I'll give
me one
sec um officer Welch officer W what did
I do to
you
off nothing directly nothing directly to
[Music]
me
second let me get you back up pleas step
out over there on that corner door 174
just go to that door
please I change your I don't mean to I
don't mean to get sh
sorry
DUI there he
is
Buddy I've been waiting on him and the
two last two people weren't even the
people you want this SH
now
[Music]
I'd
like
I'm want to blow and see yeah and it's
just been a a
of yeah see you later see you l hey
sorry for giving trouble dude
hey hey is that right there from
England hey my
[Music]
bad
so I'm also going to gra a picture this
that way you can use it
and
[Music]
Y at this time you're under arrest for
refusal
yep I'm placing under rest for where are
refuser okay um that citation will be
added to your
property I'm
uh will you be right to uh hang out for
just a
[Music]
couple all right cool just come this
way Australian the rest
of where you from hey come this
way time this
way what city here it's your business I
I wish you were rting me but not
him all
[Music]
right
you need to do call law
I test yes sir
[Music]
[Applause]
yes do you have any endorsements on your
driver's
license do you have any endorsements on
your driver's license and then you're an
to General
and you're also a defense
attack tell me sh what your shit you
want me to get you off walk out I'll be
good from Australia is arring me oh
austral have you guys talking okay now
you got stand over here for
[Music]
me
what's that top is on YouTube not
YouTube
Netflix what is it called
top TV
series know how they
can't I think I started no no I finished
the whole thing did when when you
saw how he ended up after
he I
[Music]
watch I
got how long you been in Rell Americans
for
just you come back from
Australia
no I'm
[Music]
not all right this isy Moody going do
your down on you
stand you're all good just keep your
hands up here all
righten what he
says
am I able to get up take
a say again am I able to get up and take
a piss uh one SC Stu I'll be able toide
you with
[Music]
that obviously get all
that you going to have a ride
home at least put my
handcuff
say again can I put my handcuff in front
of my ass in front of my stach uh not
right now they'll be taking you handcuff
soon I'll be taking them off
you sorry I I don't mean to
C two copies for you not because of RFI
actually turn my radi on there doesn't
matter I just realiz mine still off so I
was going to call dispatch I told so
they're so you're good to go one copy
like set just got to have that all right
awesome um good yeah I mean the only
thing I going to do is uh I got this
popped in my in my trunk and then I need
to go out and do the citation for
refusal but I mean all that I can put in
his poty box after he's booked yeah um I
just need to make sure everything here
is looking good um I don't mean hey the
guy that b me in with the city
haircut
so okay so put what
ref good there wasn't I skip that come
to maintain
L ago thank
you
and I
understand second again I already
there's going to be one more I have two
here I haven't I need to explain these
to you just to let you know too so
there's two citations here there is
going to be a third B but I'm just going
to explain these ones to you now so the
first one is going to be for driving
Under the Influence it's going to be a
$400 Bond and you have a court date set
on January the 4th 2024 at 9:30 in the
morning at the municipal
courthouse and uh this one is for the
open container court date set same date
same
time and then like said there's going to
be a third one third citation is going
to be in your property box um you may be
here you may not be one I issue to it so
it's going to be the same go cour is
going to be for D refusal when you're
refused on here that's your municipal
courthouse that's where the that's the
address of the Court's going to be and
there's a telephone in uhan there
January 4th 2024 okay and uh that's
going to be at 9:30 in the morning um so
um I let you know now and it's just let
you know so your property that I bought
with me is going to be two mobile phones
and a jacket so your two mobile phones
jacket and your Citation for Dy refusal
is all going to be brought in once
you're booked in you you may be here you
may not be if you're not here it's going
to be in your property box okay yes
sir okay so I
making I'm do the
you you not I'm sorry say okay no I just
I've I've been bothering for like an
hour I understand but you also got to
realize that I need to do my job and the
more you keep interrupting to talk to
him the more you're going to PE me off
and that's the last thing you want to do
the last thing I want to do is to
fucking piss you off I piss off I pissed
one person off I don't want to piss two
people off he you're good I appreciate
it time here huh that I say my goal when
I
came to see where you are at for
only this has nothing to do with your I
just want to see how tall you are I want
to say about
510 no without your hair yeah your hair
is like 6 without his hair it's 510 5 I
think it's 5'9 maybe
59 how much do you this has nothing to
do with your charg for housing
okay okay you got to give a steady
breath on here otherwise it's going to
keep giving me that issue
blow until it
CL like you're blown up a
balloon okay like I said this has
nothing to do with the criminal charge
this is just for them I don't want you
to say don't
love I'm ready I got to wait for it to
the last that you completed in school
steady breath what's the last grade that
you completed in school steady
breath how do I explain it like are you
single divorced can can I at least Lo
I'm not I'm not I'm not going to run or
beat anybody iar he can't do anything
with your
[Music]
CS can you loosen a little bit the soon
we get this done the soon'll be able to
take
[Music]
you yeah as soon as soon as we're done
here they they they'll take your outs
and all that good stuff I you're doing a
job
nobody
killing me I'm going to get those cffs
off you in just a second all right dude
I'm going to buy
you all right do you have anything
that's or anything like that no
sir that's but that's but top
[Applause]
you can keep that if that makes you no
molest me
less problem going stay but you know
here problem
off what's up how long you been it's
not
for Al W how long you
been when I take them off just put your
hands on the desk all right yes
sir
she'll take your ring off as
well you have to take it
off all jewelry needs to come off you
want watch
y I have you want my belt too belt has
to come up take your shoes off as
well
[Music]
so we have to do
isings signatures get you out of
here you got to have
your I'm not
[Music]
officer
mons my
shes anything
uh go ahead and go work on the citation
if need anything I
to do is Ki your foot back out towards
me at the
knee I only take people to jail or the
[Music]
ER
I'll be doing a citation not leaving
yet